all right i have a close
tight-knit circle of friends we're all
in different cities and we're all in
different areas
from local news to city government
to law financial services
and despite those different areas we
seem to share
similar stories of workplace drama
now i define workplace drama as an
annoyance that adds
additional stress to the job so again
this one
people get on your nerves not the job
itself
so as we're going through these stories
i'm realizing there has to be a better
way
for us to coexist with our co-workers
without
this much drama so i created a few steps
that have been working for me and i'm
happy to share them with you guys today
step one rewind and reflect
also known as what did i do
i want you guys to all replay your most
recent workplace drama situation
in your head like a movie ignore all the
emotion
and just focus on you but for now let's
just think about this hypothetical
so you're on a group project you each
have your own individual assignments
and then you all divide up the work
but then someone becomes unresponsive
not
answering calls they go ghost
then you or someone else has to now pick
up that additional slack
so in a brief small very tiny
lapse in judgment you vent to the nearby
co-worker
then all of a sudden your ghost comes
back and they surprisingly know
everything you just said
now what did i do in this situation
i invented to someone who was not my
confidant
why would i do that sometimes we create
this
unspoken bond with people that only
exist in our heads
they don't owe me their discretion i
just
assumed it was there so we're not going
to go down a rabbit hole
trying to figure out why they did that
it doesn't matter they did it but the
goal in this step
is self-reflection we need to focus on
what did we do
so we can avoid it in the future step
two
come back to reality also known as
it needs to stop okay so
you guys ever think about problems
before you get to work
oh it's just me okay well i'm guilty of
it
i think about all of these situations in
my head
and then i get mad just thinking about
it
so i'm telling myself no you're just
being prepared stacy
you are just making sure that you can
handle whatever they're about to throw
at you
but you're not what you're really doing
is setting yourself
up and creating this anxiety in your
head that doesn't exist
then we also have to be careful about
listening to other people's made-up
scenarios
here's what i mean let's say you're in
the break room
and you're talking to some co-workers
then all of a sudden another co-worker
comes in
no they seem to just be in deep thought
not overly cheerful but they're not rude
they come in they walk out then the
co-workers over here
begin to diagnose what they feel is
wrong with that person
they're saying things like oh they're
just mad they didn't get the job
or they're saying oh no no no during
this season they're just always
upset and you're sitting here like yep
yep that's that must be it you're
listening to this as if this is facts
meanwhile this co-worker can be in deep
thought
about literally anything they could have
just opened a pack of starbursts got
four yellows back to back
and then just trying to figure out what
happened
but you're over here listening
and you're listening to their made-up
scenario that now can impact how you
choose to interact with that person
throughout the day
whether we're creating fake stories in
our head
or listening to other people made up
stories it needs to stop
the goal in this step stop stressing
over things that
haven't happened all right step three
vent and release
it's good to have event buddy this is
your coach
your cheerleader your therapist whatever
you need them to be in the moment
this is not like the person in step one
that just happened to be an earshot
you have an established relationship
with your event buddy
now here's another scenario
you're getting ready to tell a customer
or client something that they
they just don't want to hear so as
you're in the middle of the spiel
up comes another co-worker and they
interrupt you and then says the exact
same thing
you were saying so you can't make a
scene in front of a customer you just
you got to sit back and just listen as
they do this
and you're burning up inside so what do
we do
we go to our event buddy we talk about
it
we get mad and that's the time for that
get mad get angry
curse scream do whatever you need to do
to get it out
now here's the hard part you then
have to switch that tone to positivity
i truly believe in positive and negative
energy
and it has a way of controlling our
moods throughout the day
you got to think of things like okay
where do i go from here
what can i do differently and then if
you're the event buddy
is your responsibility to lead your
friend back to the positive
now the other hard part you have to then
apply those learnings to the situation
you can't carry that resentment around
if you do
that one-off situation now becomes a
pattern
pattern behavior is harder to ignore
than a one-off situation
the goal in this step is let's turn our
productive vent session
well let's turn our vent session into a
productive conversation
step four learn a new language
also known as we need to talk
guys i personally don't like to pick up
the phone at work
i just don't i feel like whatever you
need to say to me can be an instant
message or an email
that is my work language
the only problem with that you can't
hear tone through an email
so i read emails the same way i speak
so i'm pretty sure i misinterpreted some
tones before
unless i know you so here's an example
i'm gonna show you guys an email
and i want you to read it and then i'm
gonna read it out loud
all right that was fast enough you
should have read it
stacey thank you for reaching out about
my group
at this time we will not need any
additional support going forward
if i feel we need help i'll ask you
won't have to reach out
per my last email attached below i've
outlined what i do and what you do
so we can avoid this in the future as
always
thank you for your partnership
guys that's how you read it
because there are certain words in there
that if you
hear or if you see in an email it is
safe to assume they typed it with their
middle fingers
i didn't know it then i know it now
i think i messed up some people's emails
they're correcting them
with all that said you have to know when
it is time to pick up the phone
you have to know when it is time to have
a face to face
in these face-to-face conversations are
not easy they are difficult but they are
necessary the goal is to try to
understand
the other person's perspective so you'll
start the conversation with things like
okay you got upset when i or you'll say
things like
okay you already had the situation
handled and then
i so that way you can see exactly where
they're coming from
also don't try to make people like you
we all have our own upbringings we all
have our own experiences
and we all have our own communication
styles
as the new generations are entering the
workforce we're also adapting to it
meetings are now emails emails are now
text
all sites are now skype so as we're
adjusting to that we need to at least
try to understand what type of style of
communication they use
the goal in that step is to really
understand their work language
and accept the fact that it may be
different than yours
step five recognize
and protect also known as
we need to take a walk so here's my last
scenario for one of my teacher friends
you're about to have a meeting with a
parent
and prior to it you and a co-worker you
kind of discuss it
and the co-worker tells you it's all
right i got your back
i'm going to agree with your
recommendations
so you're kind of side eyeing them
because they've burned you before
but you've had the we need to talk so
you're like we're in sync now i'm going
to trust them
you go through the meeting the parent
disagrees with you
and like clockwork the co-worker agrees
with the parent in front of you
making you look ridiculous so you just
again we can't make a scene in front of
people right so we gotta hold it in
and then after the meeting that same
co-worker
has all the audacity comes up to you and
said
crazy meeting right
yeah they're testing you now this is the
test
so that's the perfect time to just go
off right this is a repeat offender
you walked away and they came back with
it
but we're trying to avoid workplace
drama not take a cannonball leap into it
so
we have to walk away you leave that
conversation by taking the first
available exit
you're not doing this for them you're
doing this for you
you have to protect your energy
don't try to figure out why they would
do this and no more coming to jesus
conversations
it is what it is they did what they did
and given the opportunity they'd
probably do it again
but you now know that you now recognize
that
so that way you can act accordingly
we typically try to set expectations
our expectations on other people
and then get disappointed when they
don't follow through
we have to learn we have to learn to
accept
people where they are and adjust
ourselves
to handle those situations
the goal in this step is to recognize
when it is time to professionally walk
away from someone
guys i realize these steps may come off
as
saying take the high road and people
always say that
just take the high road and they
describe it as some
elegant path of righteousness filled
with rainbows and unicorns
is not that
it's embarrassing it's humiliating
it leaves this knot of resentment in the
pit of your stomach
and as you're traveling down this
amazing high road
you see billboards the things you should
have said and things you should have did
you go over there you look at the easy
road and they're chilling not worried
about a thing
but i have to admit the more i travel
down this road it does get a little
easier
petty situations they don't bother me as
much
i learn little nuggets here and there
and as i continue down this path
there seems to be more opportunities
waiting for me
i have like-minded people who want to
connect with me
projects that people want me on leaders
reaching out because they heard about me
through someone else
and the best part the need to even look
at the easy road
is no longer there guys we're not going
to change the way adults act in the
workplace
we are not and for that reason there
will
always be workplace drama
but if we stick to these steps and put
in the work
that comes with it we can learn to avoid
it
guys thank you for being my vent buddies
and thank you so much for your time